alright ladies and gentlemen let's move
on with this program are you feeling out
there tonight all right yes beautiful
night in Los Angeles the Dodgers are
winning
let's hope they keep on winning yeah
let's keep it let's keep the keep the
good vibes going and hopefully by the
end of the night week in it we can
announce that they've won so we want to
keep the program moving and right now
we're gonna bring up some of the cast
and the crew of the movie so with no
further ado let me go ahead and get them
lined up here do we have miss rosemary
Brandenburg yes this is La Bamba set
director please give her a round of
applause sorry we like to make them we
like to make them run laps before they
get here thank you it was merry mr.
mystery seyi Morales all right yeah you
know aka Bob yeah I think you guys could
just line up this way all right mr.
Taylor Hackford the producer of la Bamba
all right mr. - right on here mr. Luis
Valdez the writer and director and mr.
Jeffrey Rivas the actor who played Rudy
who will be your moderator for this
evening all right good evening everyone
how's everybody doing tonight I want to
thank Plaza and the Academy for inviting
us and myself to have this experience
with you just what it's all right thank
you thank you so I'm gonna start this
off with Luis and just say Luis how did
the story come to you and how long did
it take from beginning to the actual day
that you started filming
it's a good question you know the the
roots of all movies are fairly long and
fairly deep and you're talking about the
filmmakers in this case I think I
started working on this late in 85 right
and we got a contract going here but the
story is that my brother Daniel and I
who played Lalo actually in this film
was also associate producer played Hank
henry reyna in zoot suit and we were on
Broadway and in his dressing room on
opening night and we were up on the
second story and we were feeling pretty
big and full of ourselves so he said
we've done the the 40's we got to do the
50s but what can we do with the 50s as a
musical in New York and at that moment
we heard mariachi music and we looked
out the window and down below on 7th
Street in the heart of New York was a
abandon mariachis and they were playing
the song that my brother and I instantly
recognized la Bamba
so the answer was what are we gonna do
next and there's la Bamba playing down
the industry the mariachis had been sent
by the President to Mexico it's a very I
believe and we didn't know it at the
time but Mexico was sending his good
wishes and because it was the opening of
the first you gonna play you know on
Broadway and so one thing led to the
other Danny my brother continued to work
on finding the family on trying to find
resource materials the story of Richie
Valens for the next five years he
couldn't find anything we're talking
about 80 to 85 and but then he finally
heard that the Bob Richie's brother was
still around and so Bob shows up in our
little town of san juan bautista in the
bar that we usually went to and he says
he goes there a lot because he lives in
Watsonville
we still lived to this day but anyway he
came and we made contact with the family
my brother went to visit Connie
Valenzuela and we immediately
that we'd hit the pay dirt you know with
the family because they were eager to
get the film made and my brother Daniel
had a working relationship with Taylor
Taylor had produced his film his record
album for A&M so Danny said let's get in
touch with Taylor he has a film company
called new visions and so we took the
project to Taylor and and he latched
onto it right away you know and so we
met the family Connie was eager bob was
eager all the relatives were ready to go
so we began to work and two new visions
that was contracted to become the
screenwriter and so I began to write
late in 85 and by early 86 I had a
bruising a draft which I sent to Taylor
and the company and and they liked it
and we continued to work on it but as
time goes by I took it by year from the
moment that we latched onto Taylor and
the family it took a year to get all the
processing going say about two years
actually it's about a two-year process
to get a film made and that's fast
that's fast sometimes it's 10 years
sometimes it's 20 years but we're very
grateful and fortunate that la bamba got
made with the right people
thank you all of us all of us working
together labor of love and it's a film
that continues to keep giving to this
day I mean it's still playing throughout
the world
Taylor so what was it about this project
that you latched onto why did you latch
on to it so strongly
well like I grew up in California so in
the 50s you know la Bamba was the number
one song and most of my friends and I
grew up in Santa Barbara were Chicano so
you know the the reality of that music
was I think in my soul and I knew
Ritchie story but the important thing
that Luis was saying Danny Valdez who's
not here tonight Danny and I were very
close friends he did a fantastic show at
KCET I worked at KCET
and who's a social intervene yo who is a
very close friend of mine and and Luis's
produced that show and I saw this guy he
was he could sing he's got a great voice
he could act I mean
Danny Valdez could have played a great
Richie balanced he really could ten
years earlier exactly any-any he had it
all but you know as they say neither
Danny or I had a pot to piss him you
know we were nothing and and then 10
years later I had some luck I made a 1
film called the idol maker and then I
made a film called an officer to
gentleman and I made a I made a
production company and and I got a call
from Danny saying all right now is the
time and and I said you're absolutely
right it's perfect but Danny was the he
really was the instigator here and all I
want to say is there was only one person
that was right to conceive this because
Lewis is a great artist he's been doing
fantastic work in the theater forever
and if someone is gonna write the heart
and soul of a Chicano story it was going
to be Luis Valdez Danny and I both
agreed to that and then we had believe
it or not we had to twist his arm he
said I got other things I said you know
other things this this is your
birthright and he you Louise tell us it
wery quickly but when you hear when you
get a first draft of a screenplay I mean
the first draft usually it's completely
off we got the first strap from Louise
and it was there
we knew we were making this movie I took
him to Colombia I said we're making this
movie and there's one other thing that I
think is interesting at that time
Columbia Pictures was owned by coca-cola
and ice and I said you know this movie
is important I said you know the Latinos
are this this is a great Latino story
Richie Valens is an incredible Latino
hero and by that but there's a huge
audience here and they said well I don't
know I said this and you know you make
movies for an audience don't you say yes
the head of the studio yes and you want
to get more of him in yes well you make
nothing for Latinos
you don't make movies for Latinos and
and I said here's an opportunity right
here and he listened to me and I said if
you don't believe me talk to coca-cola
guys coca-cola markets and they know who
buy things so the thing that was an
interesting charm
from the very beginning and Lewis Lewis
made it happen so it was his vision and
he did it from his soul having grown up
in California
he knew what what ritchie valens who he
was what his family was and that's I
think what made the film great and I
just want to tag honor that that you
know that was one of the few scripts I
think there's only been three scripts
that I've read that i've actually cried
reading the script and it's all because
of that one scene where you say ritchie
Esai Morales how was your experience on
the film who taught you how to drive a
motorcycle
I just learned on the in the parking lot
off of romaine where we had in Cole
where we had a between Cole and Cahuenga
there was a parking lot across from the
the studio where I auditioned that and I
was scared because I'd ever driven a
motorcycle before but you know like
taking on a role you just it's it's a
mission and yeah oh you that's right you
were my first coach oh that's right
hello how easy they forget that's what
you were asking right that's right
that's right here I'm thinking Wow how
do I enter this but yes it was you thank
you very much I went on to buy my own
motorcycle and had to give it away
because it was so dangerous for me but
the point is that I owe a lot to this
film like you I cried tears reading this
story falling in love with this family
reading a script about a Latino family
that wasn't about being Latino you know
what I mean it was just about being
Americans with a dream loving rock and
roll in each other you know it wasn't
pedantic it wasn't talking down to
people or making us better than we were
we had our problems and I represented
most of them my character and and
I just loved seeing all the well-defined
characters rosana de Soto was a
firebrand I mean the mother you know
Connie Valenzuela let's hear it for us
Ana DeSoto let's hear it from my Rosie
the one and only Elisabeth Pena may she
rest in peace and the real-life Rosie is
here Rosie stand up and sing about stand
up there she is right here the real-life
Rosie that's my girl right there don't
nobody mess with her Rosie got blessed
80 years old down she just told me I
mean everybody even our manager Bob
Keane played by the wonderful
Joey Pantoliano this film is a
once-in-a-lifetime thing we thought it
would be the you know the the Latin wave
they kept talking about the Latin wave
but as I say the waves come and they go
and they've tried to reproduce it they
try to make Lambada and things that
sounds similar so it could be next to it
in the video shelf but nobody to this
date has put together with these two
gentlemen put together because it was a
real collaboration and the authenticity
of the Latino experience by a real
revolutionary artist mr. Luis Valdez who
is side by side with Senator Chavez and
Dolores Huerta and so many of the
struggles we didn't have a Hollywood
writer we had a real deal but also the
commercial genius of Taylor Hackford who
really cut this movie that was the first
cut was about 3 hours and 10 minutes
long but kept the life and story of this
film in a way that could still be
impactful but short enough so that the
studio's wouldn't cringe and you know
could make their there turn around so I
just got to say it was a collaboration
and and took a year of post you know it
takes a year a year I mean yeah and it
wasn't easy it was not easy but it was
well worth it and I thank them because
my career to this
de benefits from this movie and I'm very
proud of it thank you he say rosemary
being that you weren't from the Latino
community or the Chicano community what
was the biggest challenge for you in
creating this realistic real environment
that the film captured of the period and
the time well I'm a set decorator which
means that I do a lot of research for
all of my characters I do everything
from spaceships and planets that never
existed to the Flintstones that never
existed so for me it was just another
research project and it was fantastic
experience because here I had real
characters who had so much meat to their
bones that I could just sink in and I we
Swede we looked at Latino photographers
and all kinds of great stuff we had an
incredible crew who was so enthusiastic
about bringing detail and character the
piece it was such a free environment it
was it was 30 years ago before we had to
worry quite as much as we do now about
clearances so I found wonderful things
in flea markets and shops and great
stuff that it populated these
environments and helped tell the story
of these characters it's a great job
that I have because I feel like I hope
the story be told through a visual
medium and we do a set decorators do
everything inside the walls so you will
see all the pictures and the artwork and
outside the walls too it can be anything
from all the tents that you'll see in
the beginning of the film when they're
on the apricot picking farm when they
are migrant laborers and you know all
that stuff we got to look at the WPA
photographs of Dorothea Lange and all
the people that went around in the 30s
and 40s and 50s and took pictures of all
those great camps and we used all that
to feed the story and that's what we do
and that was what's is so fun and I have
just really gotten to LA a few years
before from the East Coast so for me it
was this wonderful entree into Latino
California which I so enjoyed and I
still enjoy and I still want my
favorite things in my whole life that I
got to move to California experience
this and like Eastside this movie put me
on the map I mean I I just thought you
did a movie and it got successful and
then you get to do way more movies well
I didn't realize that not all of them
are so good and not all of them are so
well written not all of them are so well
produced
we have crew members here tonight that I
am still friends with thirty years later
we made such a bond it was really really
fun Joanie is here I mean it was a great
experience we really had a good time we
bonded as a team
it was incredible we just we worked our
asses off
it was very low-budget and we just did
it and it was great thank you so how
many people have not seen the film our
people have seen the film already all
right so you know I played the leader of
the silhouettes and I so I have a double
question what's that for you know but I
got to meet the real gentleman that I
portrayed Gil roach Oh still still
playing in a band somewhere in the San
Fernando Valley but I just wanted my
question to you to is who how did you
guys get most Lobos and then the second
part is on the day of filming the Garage
Band there was a huge argument about who
is gonna sing that song and then it got
dad and just explained that process how
I ended up singing that song live I mean
charlena sure although all the songs all
the songs that I sang but the slow how
did you get lost Lobos on los Lobos as
you know you know came from east los and
they had already recorded a song update
of Richie's listen it
we all agreed it was just no question
about the fact that we could either use
Richie's original tracks but when you're
trying to do something live it's hard
because you only have to take what was
on the record and those records I mean
they're great hits but they weren't so
beautifully recorded but we had the real
thing we had a Chicano group from east
los who was brilliant I mean all the
guys in Los Lobos are still very good
friends and I called them you know I
called you know all of the guys in the
group when I went to see them actually
out here they were they were performing
in Lincoln Park and I and I went and I
went to see the Mack stage and I said
listen I'm we're doing this film and I
really think that you need to do this
music and they looked at each other and
said yes we have to that was it so they
they were fantastic and they recorded
and you know it was amazing because in
when we recorded this and one one
instance you know when we did the
opening song which was a Willie Dixon
song you know that was a miles of bad
Road you know and Willie Dixon played
even if you know who he was he was the
guy at Chess Records one of the greatest
bass players and producers ever and
Carlos Santana was also there so in this
instance Carlos Santana did the score to
our movie and he doesn't you know Los
Lobos did Richie's music so this is puta
Chicano all the way down but but I think
there's one thing that we was missing
here and we mentioned everybody which we
didn't mention is Lou Diamond Phillips
and I think I think Lewis can tell you a
story
you know Lou came from Texas and he
didn't want to play Ritchie he went play
Bob he wanted to play Bob but I could
see through his audition tape that there
was a softer good-hearted not that Bob
is in good heart of course he's
good-hearted a softer hearted
personality there underneath all of the
toughness he could be tough also but we
saw his tape and then I said let's bring
him to LA and look at him
face to face so he came and he was very
nervous but he auditioned he did
wonderfully as Ritchie you could you
could see him in his eyes I mean it's in
the eyes it's in the face and this is
after seeing by the way six hundred
actors of all kinds of ages some of them
have gone on to a success and some have
not but the fact is that we were looking
for Ritchie we were looking for somebody
born and raised in East LA and we saw a
lot of people born and raised in East LA
but they weren't the Richie that I was
looking for and the fact is the real
Richie and I know the whole family I
mean the families here but I still see
Bob a lot and and Mario and Connie and
Mario and Bob's wife Joanie I mean we
see them Connie senior the mother lived
just a few months after the movie
premiered she was already sick at heart
she had a bad heart but she survived she
came back to life for the movie and then
lasted about six months and then and
then died and was buried in the same
grave that Richie is buried in they're
both together in the San Fernando
Cemetery
but in any case Richie was very special
and in 1950 58 59 there were no Latinos
in rock and roll there were barely black
people and they created rock and roll so
a lot of black artists were covered by
white artists Pat Boone and other people
that did this because black and white
had not completely reconciled the places
in the showbiz in the music world yet
but someone like Richie who was Latino
wouldn't stand a chance if he look like
my brother Danny actually was too
indian-looking never would have made it
in reality in the movies it's something
else but not in reality so I was looking
for someone who looked like the real
Richie six feet tall very light skinned
like his mother but every deep Indian
bones you know a big kid and definitely
chicken
No we have light-skinned Chicanos widows
all over the place he was one of them
but that helped for him to pass as an
Italian I think once they change his
agent changed his name from Ricardo
Valenzuela to Ritchie Valens
he turned Italian when I first heard la
Bamba when it appeared in 1959 I said
who's singing in Spanish who is that you
know who's this guy ritchie valens he's
an Italian singing in Spanish it it
wasn't until later that I discovered
that it was Ricardo Valenzuela and that
he was singing of course a Mexican
classic la Bamba but anyway was hard to
find the real soft heart the good heart
of Richie and Lou Diamond Phillips had
that in spades
he'd done nothing but Christian films in
Texas and and he was naive in a lot of
ways but tremendously talented in all
heart
so we cast him in spite of the fact that
some people complained because he's not
Chicano or the fact that he was half
Filipino and I'd have people come up to
me and said poor Timothy's just a
Filipino where did you get this Filipino
guy in there and I say well why not
you know the Filipinos are the Hispanics
of Asia what's the problem
in any case Richie Richie as I say was
who he was Lou Diamond Phillips is the
issue of a Filipino mother and an
American sailor father so he was very
tall thinner than Richie would have been
but he had the heart quality and that
was the most important thing so we cast
him as Richie combined him with si as
Bob and and the rest is film history I
think I also want to just let you know
something about Luis you know Luis is
theater director he had his own theater
company but he's a he's a director you
know I'm a director I know a director
and Lou Diamond film as he said came
from Texas he came from Texas having
learned every line for Bob every line he
was determined to play Bob and he we
read him for Bob and Lewis went
afterwards and he said you know
he's not as tough as he say he won't be
able to play it and in this instance he
said but I bet you he could play Ritchie
so he had to he had to go out to this
young actor who thought he was coming to
have his one shot in Hollywood and say
listen you're not gonna be able to play
Bob that's a guts crook that's a tough
thing for an actor to hear and he said
but I think you could play Ritchie and
Louis in and in this instance Lewin no
no no I'm Bob I'm Bob I can't play
Ritchie and Louise said believe me Lou
you could play Ritchie
now I want you to go home and I want you
to sleep on it I want you to look at
Ritchie's lines and I want you to come
back tomorrow morning
and I want you to read Ritchie and this
is what a director does he basically
took that actor said wipe the slate
clean get Bob out of your head because
you're not gonna get that role but but
after all Ritchie's the star of the
movie go home and Lew being a really
wonderful actor went home came back and
the rest is history as Louie said but I
want to tell you that thing about Lewis
he's very very strong I just wanted to
add a little some too because I remember
I went in for Ritchie
they don't always say that and when I
read this script I was devastated and I
read the part and I've never seen a role
so well-written about a Latino and a
family and with my name on it it had my
name on it I was like oh no this is this
has literally got my name on I mean
that's a figure of speech
but it was true and more importantly it
was like channeling the real Bob and my
own father okay so there were a lot of
dad issues that I was exercising
becoming so it was funny because I
auditioned for Ritchie but my heart
wasn't kind of really in it because they
saw me for both and one of these guys or
somebody in casting called my agent
complained and said this guy's not
taking this audition very seriously
that's what I had heard
and I just I just felt the combination
of Richie and I I mean Lou and I was
well because with the word I think that
I would have used his innocence there
was an innocence about Lou especially
when he first came that translated right
to that Richie like that warmth that
innocence and well me I'm a little
different so so I just I looked at it as
and I literate and everyday let my
ethnicity come out because he was and
more in deal so I looked at this like
Bob was the base and Richie was the
treble bob was the dark side of Richie
and Richie was the lighter side of Bob
in a weird kind of symbolic way so I
thank you for for allowing me to
continue well you know I speaking of Bob
like the real Bob Bob Bunny Wailer by
Morales - well you know Bob Morales is
his real name deserves a great deal of
credit for being totally honest you see
there was no source material for Richie
story not even articles we couldn't find
anything really no book nothing
published yet so I had to do interviews
so I put Connie a senior on videotape
and asked her questions and I did the
same thing with Bob and I asked me
perfectly honest I need you to be honest
and he was you know he's a tough cookie
he's a great guy Bob but he said I was a
drunk I was this I was that I was
violent he says I was abusive to my
family if you want to write that in the
story go ahead and I have always be
grateful to him for allowing me to do
that you can't do that without
permission but Bob said go ahead tell
the story that's who I was you know and
and the fact is that that helped a great
deal
it it helped Connie to open up and and
it helped even Bob Keane who was a
little reserved as the manager also
opened up about some things but the fact
is that bob was the key and the linchpin
as far as the storytelling was concerned
and and he allowed them to connect with
us to connect with each size character
and to put together a bob that Connie
was very very pleased with she said
that's Bob even looks like Bob and so it
was an amazing experience you know
to do that whole process of picking up
Bob in real life and then putting them
on the screen in terms of the story I
don't want to embarrass you but how can
I introduce your family your right-hand
woman his wife Lupe is my husband
you should know that my wife Lupe like a
lot of my family were extras in the film
this is Hollywood you know and you had
two of your three sons are here and two
at three sons are now art please stand
and la Keane please stand up and his
fiancee Maya please stand up here we are
all of them are actors and then apart
your partner in crime from Teatro
campesino
and Phil Esparza who has a wonderful key
line given to him by Taylor yeah
he says smells he's in the bar you know
in Tijuana he says something about fish
and chicken you know yo but you know
duper's mother is also in the film and
and she was 80 some at the time and she
played the harmonica and for oh I don't
know how many years she couldn't play
the harmonica when she got married my
father-in-law god bless him refused to
let her play the harmonica so when he
died she picked up a harmonica and
started playing again
so Lupe and her sisters bought her a big
Horner harmonica which she uses in the
film and she played what is it less the
song anyway she's playing the harmonica
in the campfire well we shot that
suppose originally were gonna shoot that
up in Hollister for the first week of
shoots but it got later and later in
later so we had to push it so we brought
her to LA and the night that she
performed that she did this shot it must
have been about four o'clock in the
morning god bless her she was waiting
and waiting and waiting she's in her 80s
so when we finally set it up at four
o'clock in the morning to the campfire
she gets there and starts playing the
harmonica and and it's a wonderful
moment for the family because it's the
image of mama that still lives and she
got sick she got pneumonia as a result
of that shoot she went back home and had
to be airlifted to Stanford University
Hospital
because she almost died as a result of
doing her movie debut but but she was
very very happy another guy the snake
man
that's Philippe Icahn to one of the
original founding members of his death
row campesino he had cancer so we had to
mic him he's the one with the
rattlesnakes it was again the high point
of his life unfortunate ended shortly
afterward he was dying of cancer when he
did the film but I'm so happy that we
were able to get Taylor to agree to
higher philippic and to as as the snake
man I think I think that's the thing
about the screenplay you know and the
reason it was so wonderful is that Lewis
infused it with both you know everything
that's Chicano the the experience of
mexican-americans but also in Dios you
know Connie Valenzuela you know she has
she's at least half maybe maybe more
rocki rocki Indian she's a light-skinned
yaki man and and the thing I have to say
that to me the the heart and soul that
infused this movie was Connie Valenzuela
her nickname was Concha you know she was
as hard as conscious as the shell but
she had when we went into her house to
you know I had to get her to sign the
rights and when you go into a house and
there's an altar to Ricci in her living
room and it was Richie was like a saint
remember Richie died at 17
so we're there and and Luis had written
a very wonderful movie was true to loot
to but you know it was her her sons Bob
as exactly as e Sai said and I said
Connie you have to trust us it was Danny
and I that went in to get the rights you
have to trust us
Louise is the right person to do it but
I need you to sign this and that means
that you don't have yes or no rights you
have to way we do that's a tough thing
when you're telling a mother whose son
died at 17 who is a saint to her to
trust us and she did and thank God she
loved the movie
Conny wherever you are you know you you
were the best and I think yours your
soul is in this movie Viva Knievel
abuela so as we wrap this up because we
want to get that film is showing for you
I'm going to start with rosemary and
just say in three sentences or less what
has this movie meant to you and how does
it live on for you this movie has meant
to me that you can make films that have
a heart and a soul and that are based in
and grounded and grounded in characters
and a story and you create a surround
for them and it works and you can still
do it you could do it then and you can
still do it now I try to do it every day
of my life I'm very proud of this
project you say same question
we come all the way down this movie
means that it can be done it was done if
you put enough passion talent budget
quality people together you can tell a
story that will resonate around the
world and I'm really just grateful bad
boys put me on the map la Bamba has kept
me there ever since so I just have to
say three people that to me were the the
heart and soul this and I said it Connie
Valenzuela luis valdez and his brother
Danny without them there would be no la
Bamba
well the same thing goes to me without
without Taylor I don't think we would
have had this picture you know it
wouldn't have happened I do have one
little story when I tell I think it's
true back in 1968
Jethro campesino had just one
independent from the United Farm Workers
when a little town called Del Rey and
not knowing we were going to survive we
were living hand-to-mouth you know Papa
squanchy Lee that was our diet and and
the fact is that we were open to
farmworkers Cultural Center Centro
campesino culturally in one of the
poorest towns in California and while we
were there struggling with our struggle
there was the young Vista Peace Corps
volunteer who showed up in his early 20s
tall lanky
blue-eyed and that guy was Taylor
Hackford we none of us were anybody you
understand we were out in the boonies he
was in his early 20s we were in our
Danny wasn't even 28 I think it was
maybe 20 but the fact is that that
wonderful things can happen even in
small towns and in some ways you know
we'd be our paths cross early on years
before la bamba' and we established a
connection that is very key and central
to the process of making art you got to
do it with people that you respect and
people that you like on the other hand
the story of Richie Valens is a story of
rock and roll it's the story of
multicultural multiracial America at a
time when America had his highest hopes
in the 50s that it was going to be an
example to the rest of the world that is
our challenge today in a time when
people's ethnicity is being questioned
when the race is being condemned we must
continue to sing the song of rock and
roll to keep this country honest and
real and with that we thank our panel
the Academy we thank you for inviting us
here Plaza North Rosie called for us we
thank you enjoy the movie I don't know
are you guys gonna be staying are you
gonna leave or we may be around after
may be around but thank you very much
enjoy La Bamba